it's Michelle from loudmouth and beauty
science chemistry nerd makeup nerd
everything nerd my skin is pretty oily
so makeup setting sprays are really
important if I'm having a long day and I
don't want to look like a dolly clock so
today I'm going to look at how makeup
setting sprays work and which ones to
use if you like this sort of video give
it a thumbs up subscribe to my channel
and make sure you click on the
notification bell so you don't miss any
videos also leave me a comment letting
me know what are the topics you want me
to cover
[Music]
what exactly is the makeup setting spray
there liquid products that you spray
over your makeup they're not a hundred
percent necessary but I really like
using them makeup setting sprays do a
few different things they make a makeup
look less powdery and more blended and
more natural they can also act like a
shield to protect your makeup from sweat
and rubbing and moving around on your
face throughout the day there are two
main categories of setting spray all
setting sprays will help your makeup
look less powdery and more blended but
some of them will also add a layer on
top that shields your makeup both types
of setting sprays are called setting
sprays but sometimes the shielding type
the type that leaves a layer or film on
your skin is called a fixing spray so
how do these different products work
[Music]
fixing sprays contain ingredients that
form the shielding layer on top of your
makeup and usually these ingredients are
polymers polymers are really long
molecules that are sort of like plastics
they're good at forming a film on top of
your makeup that can last for hours in
the setting spray the polymers will be
dissolved in a solvent and that will
usually be alcohol when the setting
spray is sprayed on your skin the
droplets spread out and merge together
and the solvent evaporates to leave
behind the film the film holds your
makeup in place and a slightly
waterproof as well before it evaporates
away the solvent also dissolves your
makeup a little bit and helps them merge
together so it looks more blended and it
looks more like actual skin but if you
spray too much the solvent might
dissolve your makeup and make it run a
fine spray usually works best here
[Music]
the second type of setting spray doesn't
hold your makeup in place but they
reduce the powdery dry look and they can
help you moisturize your skin over your
makeup they also work because their
solvents dissolve the makeup a little
bit the fixing spray is tend not to have
any skincare benefits and they usually
just sit on top of makeup and don't sink
in the second type though usually has
humectant moisturizing ingredients and
these help your skin hold on to water
these ingredients are things like
butylene glycol and glycerine because
they don't need to dissolve any polymers
they also tend to have less alcohol in
them
[Music]
to tell if your spray is fixing or not
you can look at the ingredients if
there's a polymer in the first four
ingredients it will probably fix and
shield your makeup but if there isn't it
will be the second type of skincare
blending spray the true most common
types of polymer ingredients you'll find
in setting sprays are PvP which is
polyvinyl pyrrolidone and a and P
acrylates copolymers if you're looking
for a dupe of a fixing spray then
matching the polymer is a good idea
since that's the part that does most of
the work in the spray pvp is the most
popular ingredient for fixing some of
the space that have this includes
scandinavia urban decay cover FX
Maybelline L'Oreal
there are tons more I have a longer list
in the caption ap acylase copolymer is
the second most popular type of polymer
Andersen sprays from elf makeup forever
Rimmel and L'Oreal there are a few less
common polymers as well so la girl and
NYX use VP /v a copolymer pixie uses
polyvinyl alcohol some of the more
intense stage makeup brands like ben nye
and cinema secrets use acrylate / octal
acrylamide copolymer while the very
popular green marble spray uses acrylic
resins
[Music]
a lot of the polymers used in fixing
sprays are also used in hair spray and
so if you don't have a makeup setting
spray handy then hair spray can work as
well although probably won't work quite
as well as a product that's purposely
designed for your face
generally hair spray isn't designed to
have the same flex as a spray for your
face because your hair doesn't move as
much as your face and they shouldn't
have more alcohol so they were a bit
more dehydrating but it's a popular
trick that's used in theater and drag
for giving a heavier film that looks
good even if you have hot stage lights
[Music]
now you might think that the second type
of sprayed the type that doesn't fix
your makeup is less effective and less
useful but it really depends on what
you're looking for the second type is
still really useful but for a different
purpose they're really good for
moisturizing your skin after you've
applied makeup and so for example if in
the middle of the day your skin gets
really dry and flaky it has a fine
enough mist that you won't disturb your
makeup and you can still get the
moisture into your skin there are loads
and loads of sprays in this category so
for example from al genus glam glow
Innisfree Mac Marc Jacobs pixie marabou
- ooh you can also make this type of
setting spray yourself with your
favorite bunny who met Cantona just make
sure you put it into a spray bottle that
has a fine enough spray that your makeup
doesn't run
[Music]
you use both of these makeup setting
sprays in the same way after you apply
your makeup including the powder you
hold them at an arm's length away and
spray them across your face a few times
most phones recommend drawing an X or a
chi across your face with them I
personally tend to spray its stripes
down my face and then add extra around
my nose for the skincare type spray so
you can also use them under your makeup
if I'm using mascara I apply it before I
put on the mascara otherwise I tend to
end up with mascara smudges under my
eyes if I close them too hard also
definitely close your eyes when you
spray them on your face don't be like me
and take a deep breath before spray them
otherwise you might end up hacking up a
lung like some idiot I know who is
definitely not me and so that's all for
me today if you're a fan of beauty
science please subscribe to my channel
you can also follow me on my blog
Instagram and Facebook and hopefully
that will fill all your beauty science
needs if you have any topics suggestions
feel free to leave them in the comments
and I'll see you next time
you